benjamin castaldi dans tpm p ça donne ça
c'est parti bonsoir bonsoir les hommes
benjamin castaldi c'est avant tout un
animateur d'envergure classe et élégant
avec un humour raffiné est toujours
tourné vers la subtilité
non on déconne benjamin c'est surtout le
regard de paix sur un plateau télé et
puis ce qui caractérise benji c'est
aussi sa bonne humeur toi ta gueule tout
de suite tu as fait a tout de suite mais
je me casse son point fort il manie
l'art du déguisement à la perfection
merci beaucoup d'être magnifique et
merci jean michel maire
[Applaudissements]
son point faible
une articulation digne de jean michel
maire samedi soir à 4h du mat
il ya dix ans il avait la carte pôle
emploi maintenant il a la carte du spa
du sport plazza x pour crime de crime
par pierre bel air et damidot et sous
écoute et dans l'émission et surtout les
examens problème oui je choisis mon fils
benjamin castaldi c'est aussi des
secousses à des documents sont là le est
dit il a un passé judiciaire qui est
absolument nice mme lévy cité par les
orthophonistes et aimé de tous
en résumé casta benjamin castaldi fait
sens pour ça que plateau l'ont dit avant
d'accueillir kalil combat que vous nous
donner les notes de bachar al assad et
vous nous direz vous nous dites que vous
en pensez et vous donner la note
également chez vous on va démarrer par
christine kelly a qu'à bord avant de
donner les notes votre appréciation
mon appréciation une appréciation
félicitations non non ça ouais ouais bon
alfonsi et l'alouette c'est ça l'amour
est aveugle non ok j'apprends j'aurais
pas dû commencer alors c'est un garçon
pour rester dans la métaphore du
football qui joue collectif
voilà c'est vrai je dis bravo à benjamin
parce qu'il aurait pu venir en disant
j'ai une énorme carrière je suis une
immense star donc je la joue diva oui il
va justement et continue il aurait été
quand il est chroniqueur il est 100%
chroniqueur il passe la balle il apporte
des infos est il vraiment il fait d
enquête très fouillée
bref où il n'est pas langue de bois
pas du tout et voilà et il mouille la
chemise on l'a vu l'aï vraiment il se
déguise en tout et n'importe qu'elle
accepte de ressembler à rien et c'est un
très bon gars voulaient fait et c'est un
très très bon camarade et serait
négligeable quand on est une bande de
chroniqueurs d'avoir un quelqu'un ce
serait dur à sauter d'une qu'en
maintenant disent qu'il faut vraiment
qui règle son problème de transit
et c'est un gros gros soucis je ne vous
cache pas surtout quand il commence à
faire chaud ça ma serre et et puis il
est soupe au lait il se vexe très
paisible et ils m'ont très vite dans les
tournois mais voilà voilà voilà une
excellente note parce que pour moi c'est
un excellent camarade de neuf très vite
assez rapide ipod et ce soir allez
madame isabelle brunet bmc mois on y
allait de mieux en mieux au physique ou
psychique il est toujours partant pour
faire des conneries le prouve
hiroshima au boulot c'est une bonne
gagneuse c'est un excellent 5000 blagues
sur les mariages il s'en formalise pas
donc ça c'est formulaire excellent
remplaçant de vendredi je peux en
attester
en revanche tout au moins on sait
qu'avant dans les discussions je sais
bien que ici on n'aime pas trop quand
c'est nuancé mais je te trouve des vins
plus violents sur les autres
chroniqueurs donc forcément chez moi
parce que des fois j'en patty est alors
moi il ya un vrai problème tu sais les
vieux sentant moins bien et c'est vrai
que quand articule pas moi je comprends
pas c'est le vrai souci mais je t'adore
jeter mais avant je t'aimerai après ma
maison de retraite et donc je te mets à
un formidable 8
vous riez c'est une vanne mais je la
ferai pas aussi aux nazis
si on verra mais c'est une catastrophe
oui allez-y alors moi avait compris de
quoi si peu j'ai compris donc pour moi
félicitations et jeudi premièrement il
m'a fait un très bon accueil et
j'apprécie beaucoup parce que lorsqu'on
est nouvelle et comprend un cherche ses
marques retrouve qui en a fait un très
bon ep revendre à sa prochaine femmes
actives barack obama deuxièmement je
trouve qu'ils cherchent les infos il
cherche toujours à avoir des infos
j'apprécie beaucoup il est toujours de
bonne humeur ça aussi j'apprécie
beaucoup qu'est ce que j'avais noté zopa
l'espoir salaire avec lui et c'est sa
moto dérision et son autodérision voilà
voilà
après oman points négatifs je n'en ai
pas je suis désolé je veux bien faire
exception et la note que j'avais prévu
c'est aussi comme valérie bénaïm donne à
notre brave haut à toi tu as fait une
bonne saison reste une grande mémoire de
télévision serait à presque 30 des
lumières oui mémoire de la télévision
ils n'apportent beaucoup de choses tout
âge de plus en plus et surtout tu
excelles de la reine des neiges donc
bravo prépare ça c'est en revanche point
négatif bruxelles dans la reine des
neiges et parfois tu fais des
interventions sinusoïdale ça dépend des
fois t'es tu es traîne dans parfois un
peu plus retirés bon ça arrive
appréciation finition félicitations tu
multiplies les cordes à son arc
poursuite expertise je t'adore huitard
maxime daigneault grecque qui nous a
fait l'horoscope sur quel ton monsieur
le maire a alors points forts je vous ai
je vous dérangeait pas du tout j'étais
concentré c'est pour ça qu'on aille
là-bas jamin c'est vrai c'est un vrai
caractère il est sanguin certes mais
j'aime bien les gens qui ont des
opinions catherine shanghai en amour et
en deux modèles et en deux ans est
devenu un personnage incontestable de
l'émission donc bravo points forts aussi
tu as vraiment des vrais des vraies
bonnes infos du fait de ta carrière et
du fait aussi état beaucoup de soirées
arrosées avec tes potes producteurs tu
rapportes des infos et ça c'est plutôt
bien malheureusement tu as des points
faibles pour principal c'est que tu es
très inégale un jour tu es très éveillée
tu resplendit le deuxième jour tu es
complètement transparente eu à côté de
moi parfois c'est grâce à tes coûte que
je sais que tu es là
[Applaudissements]
le deuxième est le deuxième point faible
qui est plus grave encore ces shoots est
devenu en deux ans les joueurs de boules
mais de ouf le plus grand des champs de
boules de l'histoire du paf
beaucoup de séries sont plus lisses que
des boules de billard aujourd'hui deux
et c'est l'explosion
expliquez-nous ce à l'échangé - les
shows de boucane
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
mais c'est vrai c'est moitié c'est lui
qui lâche tes boules c'est moi qui
dégoûte veut savoir ce qui va se passer
ce n'est pas de mal n'ya pas de mal
gilles verdez alors on cherche en bien
j'ai trouvé un point fort c'est que vous
mouiller le maillot
c'est vrai vous déguisez vous chantez
vous faites tout ce qu'on demande mais
en revanche la liste des points faibles
elle s'allonge de jour en jour c'est
vrai ou somnoler où vous pétez mais dés
que vous parlez on ne comprend rien et
de plus en plus et ça c'est très grave
regardez-moi baissez pas les yeux à la
solde de vos amis producteurs qui vous
dictent vos interventions et ça je ne le
supporte pas peut-être que vous avez des
infos comme dit cyril mais voulait
garder pour vous en permanence c'est
d'ailleurs mieux parce que sinon elles
sont pernicieuses
car castaldi regardez-moi net vicieux
vous êtes vicieux je vous accorde donc
et cette exceptionnelle un excellent
deux car c'est votre deuxième saison
mais si vous continuez comme ça pour la
troisième jamais vous n'aurez 3
[Applaudissements]
ce qui met des bonnes notes
je ne sais pas après avoir laissé parler
juste les deux filles hystériques
moi j'adore benjamin castaldi c'est vrai
qu'il a un côté un peu brutes épaisses
comme ça un peu petter mais bon camarade
je trouve pas été incontestablement
l'épiné de l'avant droit j'ai une
affection particulière pour ton sourire
je suis arrivé en même temps que toi il
ya maintenant un peu plus de vent un peu
moins de deux ans et je trouve que dans
ton sourire et à tous il ya des
souvenirs et des larmes
sadji ya peut-être devenu une histoire
d'amour qui remet à terminer et je
trouve que dans ton sourire il ya toute
une histoire l écart est hors du parc
magnin cyril écoutez moi c'est beau ce
que je dis c'est de la poésie
merde alors et donc je te mets un
magnifique huit fédérations
[Applaudissements]
moi je trouve que c'est un très bon
camarade il a de très bonnes âmes faut
il est vraiment sympa avec nous ça se
passe très bien avec lui il n'y jamais
non à quoi que ce soit et on le dit mise
en place d'un beau mariage
on fait ce qu'on veut avec lui etc il ya
qu un point faible si on peut être vache
c'est l'articulation parfois il est vrai
et c'est parfois sans lui on veut dire
articule quand tu pètes à 7 1 bouteille
benjamin d'humeur égale tous les jours
toujours prêt pour l'adar cas j'aime ta
bienveillance et pour ça je te mets à 8
les félicitations
la note de benjamin adam d'accueillir
camille combal la note de castaldi note
des chroniqueurs 6,1 note est tout aussi
vous avez une moyenne de 6,8 yuans
[Applaudissements]